nous arrivons un article 16 monsieur
poisson vous êtes inscrit sur l'article
non monsieur Houillon non plus je n'ai
pas là donc plus monsieur va être non
plus monsieur le retour non plus
chez Monsieur seigneurie non plus
monsieur Lassalle
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
l'occasion de dire hier soir seul
ministre combien il me semblait que ce
projet de loi
peut se permettait de voir un ensemble
de dossiers que personnellement je
croyais à vous et que l'on aborde rien
jamais à partir de là
force de constater que nous restons
quand même ce ministre sur une
trajectoire qui à mon sens n'est pas
bonne excusez-moi mais chers collègues
mais nous ne sommes pas remis de la
dernière réforme de la justice afin du
moins sur mon territoire
ce qu'a fait monsieur Vals avec la
réforme territoriale va affaiblir
considérablement notre territoire nous
le verrons dans deux ou trois ans ou 4
quand je dis notre territoire c'est
notre image territoire des campagnes
territoriales ce ne sera pas mieux pour
le vendre urbain et je vois qu'avec
cette tentation de concentration sur des
professions qui au fond nos demandes
rien à personne et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'on dit certains de
mes collègues
moi aussi je rencontrais grand nombre de
notaires d'avocats d'huissier de
commissaire priseur je n'en ai pas
trouvé un seul qui trouve crédit qui
trouve qui trouve qu'il y avait quelque
chose de bon à cette proposition alors
je sais bien que c'est le problème du
changement que la France est retire au
changement je sais tout ça mais quand
même trouver autant de résistance c'est
quelque chose qui m'interpellait et la
pertinence la constance des
raisonnements alors j'en viens me poser
la question suivante c'est que est-ce
que nous allons un jour réussir à
dépasser les travaux préparatoires de la
haute administration de notre pays
qui passent son temps à préparer les
projets
complètement déconnecté du territoire
mais qui ont tous leur effet c'est de
recentraliser alors que c'est le
contraire qu'il faudrait faire parce
qu'on peut faire beaucoup de choses
madame la Présidente mais voyez-vous
lorsqu'on a perdu la culture d'un
territoire il est très difficile de
l'acquérir nous le voyons actuellement
avec des médecins lorsque nous aurons
recentralisé le seul ministre nous
aurons amenés par la force des choses de
quelqu'un notre bien expliqué tout à
l'heure déjà se regrouper parce qu'ils
diront intérêt nous aurons les pires
difficultés à re-étaler et à retrouver
une administration de notre territoire
et en
une justice qui soit équilibrée moi je
pense quand même que c'est un très gros
problème nous promettons pendant les
élections moins énervées et nous ne
pouvons pas tenir parce que lorsque nous
arrivons au pouvoir excusez-moi ce
raccourci mais c'est ce qui fait le
mieux comme prendre nous noterons devant
un projet rose si c'est une majorité
rose et un projet bleu si c'est une
majorité bleue mais le contenu est le
même depuis 25 ou 30 ans et ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas compris je
vous assure que cette fois-ci ça ne sera
pas compris ni par les notaires ni par
toutes ces professions dont nous avons
parlé et moi quelque part je me dis
qu'un grand pays comme le nôtre qui est
capable de telle fulgurance qui est
capable de réfléchir de voir loin et
quand même un petit peu embourbé depuis
une vingtaine une trentaine d'années sur
des textes qui vont toujours la même
sens merci madame la Présidente merci